let's jump to the story from the Daily
Mail because we all care so much about
Joe Rogan's opinion bleeding heart
liberal Joe Rogan says he'd vote for
Trump before Biden because he's mentally
gone and Americans now have to rely on
his on his side show of diversity
Administration he was talking to Russell
Brand
he basically said that
now look Russell Brand and Joe Rogan are
very similar kind of guys liberal-ish
comedians ones you know he's a British
guy one's an american guy and here they
are talking to each other and Rogan's at
the point now where he said in the past
he wouldn't vote for Biden but he
wouldn't he didn't vote for Trump now
he's saying he'd vote for Trump before
Biden which is you know Joe's moving
over a little bit see here's what I
think
you got a lot of liberals who know in
their heart of hearts Trump is the right
answer albeit an imperfect one but you
definitely can't support Biden
and they don't want to say it because
they're scared so they'll they'll
they'll play a middle of the road kind
of game and act like they're some
centrists or whatever or they're
disaffected but they won't just come out
and say the truth so we see this with a
lot of these politically homeless people
on Twitter well where they will still
promote an obviously fake story smearing
Trump just to try and be like oh and to
that point Russell Brand sang MSNBC and
Fox News are just as bad any honest
assessment of the facts would show you
that Fox News while not perfect is
substantially more factual than MSNBC
even News Guard thinks so and that's an
establishment news writing agency but
you still get these people
who are going to be like oh you know I
wouldn't vote for Trump I'm not going to
do it I don't know I wouldn't be
surprised to find out that Rogan
actually did vote for Trump now if he
says he didn't I believe him but if if
he came out said you know actually I did
vote for him I'd be like oh that didn't
surprise me at all but the fact that
he's saying it now I think we're going
to start seeing more of a pushback
there's this viral video of this woman
being like let me tell you about frog
and frog self pronouns and how to use
them and then a guy goes that's it I'm a
republican he sucks down and he's like
frog self
the Frog gender and so this guy's like
I'm a republican you got me I'm out I'm
vote Republican because I'm not gonna
call the person a frog it ain't
happening when you're offered Donald
Trump or frog self
that's that's really what we're being
given we're being given Donald Trump
who's kind of crazy or completely
detached from reality it's like a form
of radicalization but in the reverse
sense like I hate that thing so radical
move uh well this is what the left Dude
too and my husband talks about this um
and he wrote a book about it because he
had experience in the far right and
um
he talks about and I feel like it was
starting to happen to me when I got docs
by antifa and all that but they push
people to be more Radical by acting the
way that they are you know like they do
these things to people they're saying
these frog sell things or whatever and
it pushes people like all the way to the
other end
the response the reason that well the
response to Communism is almost always
fascism
right people get sick and tired of the
complete Insanity and so then they're
just like well who's gonna make things
normal and that's what that's what
Hitler did in in the uh or the art the
argument that the Nazis made not what
Hitler did the argument that the Nazis
made to get elected or when they were
trying to get elected was we will
restore order we all the fighting in the
streets will stop because there was so
much agitation from antifa the
Communists in why the Weimar Republic
and the response from the population is
we're fed up with this Insanity so we
want someone that's going to give us Law
and Order and it's always and it pushes
to an extreme and I felt that way when
when they did all that they did to me
ruined my career doxed me like did all
the stuff just destroyed my life it
almost made me want to just go
completely the other end when they're
calling me a Nazi you know but you have
to like control that and and to not kind
of buy into that but it's also dangerous
when they're calling people like Tucker
Carlson or regular normal people nazus
that's also going to push people to like
the far end like okay well I guess we're
all Nazis then so what's a better
Victory to engage in fascist Crackdown
Law and Order or just mockery let okay
so there's more than two choices the
other one was realism
using mockery no well Tim's right
mockery mockery is a way to fight them
but the the the ideology or or not the
ideology but the political path that the
United States needs to get Beyond is a
liberal path now there's going to be
people that are going to say we can't
you know liberalism can't take uh can't
take authoritarian impulses because
liberalism is innately uh naive I guess
is what a lot of people would say you
you're you're you're your impulse is to
listen to the argument from the from the
classical liberal yeah I don't and I
don't believe as a classical liberal
solution yeah so but like Tim says like
there's some people that don't believe
it because they don't believe that that
voting will will work they don't believe
that because of intimidation and stuff
like that and I get it but I think that
the options are authoritarianism or
liberalism so you get right
authoritarium theoretism
I mean it's not authoritarianism versus
libertarianism libertarianism is not
binary it's it is a gradient so you can
be the moderately authoritarian or
moderately libertarian you can be Center
in between and I think the issue is the
people who are classically liberal have
traditionally been in a sort of it's I
would say they're they're Centrist
libertarian types that are not all the
way down at the bottom towards Anarchy
but they're not quite conservative
they're not leftist or anything and
these people allow authoritarians to do
whatever they want which means you need
a more I don't know service guarantee
citizenship kind of approach where you
get your constitutional rights I mean
Starship Trooper style service
guarantees citizenship if you're not a
member of the community who's
contributing you don't vote on things
that solves the problem very very
quickly now the problem however is it
could also exacerbate the problem very
quickly which is why some have proposed
it because if those institutions get
captured who gets let in to perform
Services who gets a to vote it could it
could isolate very very quickly the
simple answer is you still need a strong
moral foundation and you need I guess
what you would call a cultural tradition
in which the people that you agree with
come together periodically organize
together speak to one another have
something that bonds them together and
they reject outside of it and that needs
to be the dominant umbrella so when I
say mockery what I mean to say is Jimmy
Kimmel
this is what he does
he goes on TV and Aaron and takes a clip
of Aaron Rodgers saying I'm looking
forward to seeing if the Epstein list
list gets releasing my gets released and
then Jimmy Kimmel laughs at him and
calls him a tin foil hat guy what he's
talking about a news story about I've
seen Client List I mean Elaine Maxwell's
in jail this stuff's happening she got
convicted how is that tinfoil hat what
he's doing is he's trying to create the
sphere of influence to say this is what
you must be if you want to be safe in
our society
the right needs control of those
institutions it's not going to be this
let us come together and have a debate
on stage and discuss the merits of your
uh critical race Theory it's going to be
no we we despise you you're a moral
crackpot cultists and we're going to
make fun of you and we are going to
command the institutions and then we're
going to say you are not welcome to
speak here but the good the liberal
tactic would be to get in with Jimmy so
that he trusts you and then mock make a
mockery of him in public on his own show
to show why he's wrong and then get all
his followers to follow you instead
that's not a liberal tactic that would
be like a peaceful like
liberal approach as a speech and debate
yeah the subversive get into his show
and then undermine him is actually not
that's the point of debate is you get in
contact with someone and then you
undermine them in the process no see the
issue is you have sophists and you have
uh liberals and the Liberals are saying
sit down with me good surf or I might
have a conversation to change your mind
and they say oh There's an opportunity
to lie and twist the facts and take
videos out of context to recruit more
people to my cult yep and liberals keep
going I can't figure out why I'm losing
imagine sitting down a game of Monopoly
and just letting your your friend be
like no you don't got to pay rent this
time I get it you're hurting your friend
goes I just don't have any money I can't
pay you I'm gonna lose if you make me
pay this time okay and then he's got a
huge wad of cash under the table and
he's buying up properties left and right
that's basically what it is I think it
would be more like you infiltrate into
the network somehow get your own show
and then start subliminally putting in
those jokes of your own or whatever
instead of just like getting on Jimmy
Kimmel and converting those like you
need to get into the institution like
get into the networks get into the
universities get and slowly do what they
did and start changing Minds like a
little bit at a time not everyone has to
be like extreme championing like a cause
get in there slowly yeah and once you
get in the institution starts to change
you and you have to remain steadfast not
because Jon Stewart it's kind of like
that he's sort of able to see the Wuhan
through it all but he's still being
affected and transformed by the
institution being a part of it you say
John Stewart Stewart yeah well I mean
he's like a super Lefty yeah but he's
still able to see like truth really from
time I mean he called out the Wuhan
really virus coming out of Wuhan pretty
clearly earlier he deserves one Colbert
he deserves nothing yeah but I mean he's
a he's also he made a show crapping on
white people like he is entrenched he
stepped out of line because he's an old
fogy who did not know what that what the
cult wanted and so he goes on TV
thinking he was being himself and then
quickly went uh oh did I say the wrong
thing they're calling me racist now and
then he does a show called something
about like the problem with white people
yeah I just saw him get a clip with
somebody and he was on his own show
dismissed a real demeaning about it and
also I was about not letting kids go to
drag shows and he was like what's the
point of that anyway what's the real
deal gun violence let's talk about gun
violence you're like dude because it's
sexualizing children the whole thing the
whole thing was a mess it was it was if
you watched the the whole thing the guy
that he was interviewing almost said
almost nothing and it was all edited so
that way John basically Jon Stewart used
the guy just to do all these off of I
think Sullivan I guess he has his name I
think never do digital interviews man
Sullivan did a digital interview I I
think that's no they were face to face
and the one I was I'm thinking about it
might be Bill Maher or whatever you do
these digital shows and then you're cut
out from the room and they usually use
you as a prop that's why I don't do
digital here I think John's an example
of someone that infiltrated the liberal
media to change it I know he was
extremely politically active wanting to
get his views across I don't know if
he's necessarily top tier intellect you
know you know of our time but he's also
been transformed by that process that's
that's one of the downsides Jon Stewart
spent 20 years making well maybe not 20
years however long he was on uh he spent
the entire time that he was on The Daily
Show making any Republican or rep or
conservative idea completely radioactive
well to be fair though he defended James
O'Keefe several times did he no no yes
he did several times and he uh gave and
he was honest in what uh James O'Keefe
had uncovered with Acorn and the acorn
thing that's right and he was like how
how did journalists miss this story how
is up to this guy and he shows a young
James wearing the the pimp outfit or
whatever there's still the damage that
he's done by making conservative ideas
radioactive has been has been far worse
than than antifa honestly thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time